bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation la fraude et la
criminalité financière se porte bien
hélas elle pourrait même s'accroître
dans les prochaines années ce sont en
effet les conclusions d'un livre blanc
publié par la société devrait ware est
titré fraude le fléau aux mille visages
pour en parler je reçois xavier guillon
directeur fraude et criminalité
financière chez deveryware bonjour
xavier houillon revoir les laissions
petite présentation votre entreprise
alors deveryware est une société
française avec une présence à
l'international puisque nous sommes
présents en afrique du nord et du sud
est essentiellement en europe qui est
leader en france en la matière de
technologies d'investigation qui met
dans les services sur la protéine en
matière de sécurité globale d'accord
alors c'est quoi ces technologies
d'investigation pour qu'elles fekter
alors nos offres avec nos filiales
principe est prise au tec nous
permettent de couvrir un ensemble
d'analysés en matière d'investigation
qui vont de l'investigation numérique
l'investigation judiciaire la cellule de
crise les appels d'urgence ou encore la
plateforme de géolocalisation en temps
réel et bien sûr de la lutte contre la
fraude donc vous pouvez être appelés à
travailler à la fois pour des
entreprises mais aussi des institutions
publiques pour les thalys faire la
justice et c'est exactement c'est ce que
le groupe des verts fait depuis sa
création s'est elle met à profit ses
compétences et ses savoir faire au
profit de différents ministères pour
pouvoir aider les enquêteurs et les
unités d'investigation et par voie de
conséquence au profit des entreprises et
des populations très rapidement c'est
quoi la fraude pour qu'on comprenne bien
votre sujet alors concrètement la fraude
c'est tarnac qui permet d'obtenir des
fonds d'une façon illicite avec
l'apparence la plus légale possible et
on a bien compris qu'aujourd'hui on est
tous victimes de la fraude ces mêmes
aujourd'hui l'actualité du monde sont
les états les entreprises vous et moi
les populations alors aujourd'hui parce
qu'on se concentre évidemment sur les
entreprises une entreprise sur quatre en
france aura été victime d'une fraude
c'est à peu près exactement ce sont les
derniers sondages qui ont permis de
dresser ces constats qui sont assez
alarmants et jeu un don de voyance je
peux vous dire que si on fait rien de
plus demain ça sera deux sur ktm après
demain ça sera trois sur quatre et on
peut estimer qu'au niveau européen qu'au
niveau mondial c'est à peu près la même
chose ou pas wi fi dans certaines dans
certaines régions du monde on est sur
des constats beaucoup plus alarmant à
risque effectivement tout le monde n'a
pas aujourd'hui le même niveau de
technicité de protection ressources et
de protection et voire même de
sensibilisation puisque le postulat
frotter sur sa capacité de sensibiliser
avant de lutter faut savoir qu'elle
existe et comment le s'affiche elle
s'adresse à vous alors il ya plusieurs
types de fraudes on va voir mais en tout
cas l'impact très négatif si on compte
seulement en termes de perte de chiffre
d'affaires pour une entreprise je crois
même pour les états d'agir en taxes
impôts etc on est dans plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros voire sur
certaines fraudes à la tva plusieurs
milliards c'est ça alors c'est une très
bonne question puisque aujourd'hui
figurant la fraude vous l'avez évoqué à
juste titre s'est interloqué génériques
oui mais elle comprend un ensemble de
différentes fraudes dans différentes
activités dans différents secteurs
d'activité et par différentes graphies
donc tout ça pour dire que les unités de
valeur que vous venez d'évoquer on parle
de millions de saint-émilion parfois
c'est par fraude on parle même de
milliards et ça touche le secteur et
bâtiment gouvernemental public est
effectivement le secteur privé et
aujourd'hui c'est cet ensemble qui
représente des sommes considérables pour
lesquels au propose des solutions qui
vont permettre effectivement de se
protéger de se prévenir de sensibiliser
de lutter et d investiguer parce que la
bonne nouvelle dans tout ça c'est qu'il
y existe des solutions alors depuis la
porte des buts qu'ovide et le
télétravail est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il ya de plus en plus de fraudes ça a
été un véritable accélérateur arrête
c'est à dire qu'en fait la fraude existe
depuis tout en continuant elle existera
encore demain puisque elle a cette
capacité à se réinventer en permanence
pour autant le télétravail et du
déstabiliser nos procédures nos process
et parfois même des entreprises qui
n'étaient pas suffisamment déjà visé est
prémuni sur le sujet de la fraude ont
subi un véritable accélérateur on a
changé les méthodes on n'a pas forcément
eu le temps de les anticiper on n'a pas
phares sont attendus protéger ces
nouveaux canaux de communication et ses
éventuelles nouvelles procédures et
l'impact a été direct on a pu le voir
voire même avec eux les ventes de
masques les ventes de file de gel ou il
ya eu des escroqueries sur des sites
internet au moment des pénuries où il
n'y avait pas de new delhi dionne ce
n'est pas cette sensibilisation de se
dire mais peut-être que c'est une fraude
ou une arnaque on était dans la
précipitation on était dans l'urgence
qui a un vecteur un accélérateur pour la
fraude et qui est venu mais profiter
pleinement de ces crises qui sont des
accélérateurs les top 3 des pires fraude
contre les entreprises sera rapidement
c'est quoi vous avez la fameuse offre
deux présidents alors ce serait passé
pour le président et c'est
extraordinaire ce qu'elle existe depuis
10 ans maintenant et elle a toujours ce
que ceux
de transférer des fonds évidemment dans
un dieu qui le mien coup voilà vous vous
êtes un petit contexte d'urgence d'exo
confidentialité et puis ensuite derrière
ça vous alimentez donc ce qu'on appelle
l'empreinte numérique c'est toutes les
traces que vous laissez à titre
personnel sur internet par les réseaux
sociaux des abonnements des choses comme
ça et autres et qui font que les
criminels vont se servir de ça pour
pouvoir vous manipuler ce que l'idée
c'est vous manipulez pour vous faire
croire et vous amener à un degré de
confiance dans l'opération donc donc
évidement cette fraude extraordinaire
dans sa le dans sa logistique
puisqu'elle représente des milliards
chaque année à l'échelle planétaire va
continuer à occuper la première place et
du suivi derrière ça ensuite des fraudes
aux faux ordre de virement et les fraude
identitaire en règle générale qui
viennent usurpé des identités pour se
faire passer pour un client voire même
pour un prestataire et c'est une
solution les solutions aujourd'hui elles
sont dans un premier temps des solutions
de sensibilisation de formation et
d'acculturation c'est très difficile de
dire je vais les luttes et mettre en
place un système si je ne maîtrise pas
bien ce à quoi chaud je suis exposé donc
c'est d'identifier la menace les
meilleurs et les menaces existant qui
est menaces éventuellement de demain
d'avoir une sensibilité par rapport à
savoir une veille et une forme de veille
c'est au parlement d'une mécanique et
ensuite dans un second temps de pouvoir
mettre en place des dispositifs ces
dispositifs ont passé par de la
formation vont passer par des procédures
et ensuite mon passé par éventuellement
des solutions technologiques
parce que la technologie va permettre de
faire recouper les signaux faibles et
ces signaux qui vont alerter en un mot
avant d'être ans l'incidence mais
attention ce que vous dites dans le
livre blanc c'est oui pas 100% confiance
à la techno exactement qui est des
hommes et des femmes derrière toujours
exactement un logiciel de lutte contre
la fraude que vous pleurez que vous
branchez sur 1,38 ça n'existe pas et ça
n'existera pas pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui on à la petite est de
détecter de façon automatisée des
signaux faibles assez rapide pour autant
il faut l'humain folle expertise c'est à
dire que dès lors que vous arrivez sur
des niveaux de complexité en matière de
fraude et c'est ce qui est le but d'une
fraude ainsi pu aller complexe qu elle
et elle est en apparence propre puis va
falloir aussi apporter une expertise une
expérience humaine qui va se combiner
avec la partie technologique et c'est ce
résultat qui va être efficient les
entreprises mettre suffisamment d'argent
ou pas sur les hommes les ressources
humaines et sur la techno aujourd'hui on
voit bien que les entreprises sont dans
un virage donc certaines entreprises de
par la nature même de leur activité ont
pris ce virage un peu plus tôt que les
autres et d'autres attendent toujours un
petit peu l'accident pour pouvoir réagir
et s'organiser on le voit aujourd'hui on
est beaucoup trop en réaction 1 or nos
solutions c'est d'accompagner les
entreprises en prévention si phénologie
très simple il faut pas attendre que le
verre soit dans la pomme nous ce qu'ont
proposé d'essayer d'éviter que le ver
est dans la pomme et c'est de protéger
l'entreprise et quand on parle de
protection pas que d'un modèle
économique on preuve le protéger ses
salariés de protéger son activité ses
actionnaires sa gouvernance ses clients
sa réputation le climat social le risque
éventuellement de sanctions
réputationnel donc le risque
réputationnel et enfin aussi tout ce
qu'on en oublie un peu aujourd'hui la
politique rse et tout ce qui va derrière
avec la le côté environnemental
si je prends l'exemple du trafic de
déchets qu'une fraude ont dit bon bah
c'est juste une fraude voilà les déchets
auprès des migrants moins aimé sauf que
derrière et des conséquences sur
l'écologie la santé publique etc donc il
ya toute la chaîne de responsabilités
qui va suivre derrière et les
conséquences qui aujourd'hui impacte les
conséquences
daschle frauduleux prise de conscience
des entreprises des institutions
publiques également au niveau européen
où on voit une agence qui s'intéressent
de plus en plus à ces questions 2200
enquête de l'olaf 1 pour recouvrement
près de 7 milliards d'euros donc là
aussi ça bouge mans oui alors vous
faites état notamment ses fameux 7
milliards qui concernait les deux
mémoires les subventions européennes qui
avaient été détournés ou en tout cas
obtenu de façon parfois illégales
effectivement on se rend compte
aujourd'hui de cette sensibilité et on
assume un petit peu plus le sujet de la
corruption et surtout le fait que la
finance parce que la fraude c'est ça
reste un flux financier une fille née
avec la dématérialisation s'est tout de
suite une affaire internationale et donc
à l'échelle européenne heureusement que
nous avons effectivement cessé organisé
l'office européen de lutte antifraude
qui marche bien et qui a donc venus re
est renforcée par le parquet européen a
créé par 22 états exactement donc c'est
une récente mesure qui le parquet
européen a débuté ses fonctions en juin
2021 dernier et invocations a
effectivement ouvrir des enquêtes
surtout pour la protection économique de
l'union européenne
essentiellement il retrouve la fraude à
la tva et aussi tout ce qui peut être
potentiellement des actes de corruption
d'agent ou d'acteurs étatiques avec
n'aurait pu intervenir que ce soit dans
les marchés publics les octroi de
subventions et autres ce que vous aussi
dit très bien dans votre livre blanc
c'est que la fraude est dû aussi en
partie par la facilité incroyable pour
créer une entreprise aujourd'hui parce
que c'est toujours souvent à l'origine
on manque de vigilance clairement là
dessus c'est trop facile de créer une
entreprise alors aujourd'hui on est on
est tous à la recherche de deux
créations d'entreprise quels que soient
les pays et les états puisque l'idée
c'est de montrer le dynamisme de nos de
nos régions de nos pays il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui dans cette course parfois
un peu effrénée à la création
d'entreprise
on s'aperçoit qu'avec la fraude passe
par des personnes morales sans personne
morale le schéma frauduleux en règle
générale c'est pas qu'on n'existe pas
donc c'est vrai que le débat comporte et
c'est pas forcément débat s'est en fait
les solutions qu'on souhaite apporter
aux acteurs de ces de cet écosystème
c'est de leur dire on a décidé de vous
accompagner en amont pour éviter
justement schéma frauduleux et lorsqu on
sait qu effectivement les entreprises
sont le premier vecteur utilisé par la
criminalité parce qu'il faut briller
qu'on parle de criminels en face de nous
bah c'est de dire comment on peut faire
pour vous aider en un mot pour pouvoir
améliorer la détection avant de créer la
société merci beaucoup xavier ou lyon
pour vos réponses l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique bien terminé
mais évidemment vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur france 24 points
comme sur nos réseaux sociaux et aussi
sur nos podcasts au revoir
[Musique]